the outstanding numbers for kyle gibson
he leads the american league in era he
has had a dominant
first two months of the season
gibson's o2
and this one popped up
out near shortstop
connor faletho was in pretty good
position to begin with and makes that
play easily
run away
payoff pitch
and that one blasted to center field but
a lot of room out there and garcia takes
care of it an 11-pitch first inning for
kyle gibson he does his job and now
these rangers bats to see what they can
do no score bottom of the first and zach
littell opening the game for the giants
here
this is going to be a long throw for
vassler
right there
well done kainer falefa runs
very well
just got him
and he misses their ball four so holt
draws the walk and the rangers have the
first base runner with the ball game
oh did they get him man that was close
brock's got a couple bags on the year
the giants video room
has advised the giants and gabe kepler
to contest this call and ask the umpires
in new york to overrule the call
here's the call
he's out
so they agree with you javi
so that's a that's a great pick off
there by zach latao
now the pitch and that one is swung on
and missed strike three he got him with
a 94 mile an hour fastball so zach latel
very successful job opening the game and
now sammy long will get ready to come in
3-2 pitch and this one in the air
short right field white coming in
and he gets to his spot the inning is
over giants leave a man we played one
and a half and it's still 0-0
much talked about sami long making his
debut tremendous strikeout numbers 37
punch-outs in just 22 and two-thirds
innings with just five walks four scene
fastball change up curve slider curve
ball is the pitch for this guy
in center field steven duggar and willie
calhoun the bay area native
is out number one there is the entourage
for sammy long
herniated discs that he had suffered way
back when he was in sacramento state i
know that's
that's tough as a pitcher
and the fastball he's got a pretty good
fastball and that's his first big league
strikeout and you figure they're not
going to throw that one around the horn
that's probably getting sent back into
the dugout it did
that's just a reach back heater
down and in
and that struck him out looking three up
three that inning the sammy long
cheering section
is
very loud
one two to trump
and that is strike three called his
first strike out of the ball game
belt is on deck
and belt will come up he threw him a
change up on three and two and walked
him
at first there he goes
and off the inside
when he did go up and in
yeah this one is in play third base
and holt goes the short way to second to
take care of belt in the inning
and we've played two and a half so far
this afternoon no score five walks
against 37 strika
this pitch a little bit outside he
misses with a fast point
fastball right there strikes recall
[Applause]
curveball puts him away it's been more
the same he's getting strikeouts yeah
big curve ball knew that was the pitch
coming in you see no hump just goes
straight out of his hands straight down
cumbersome the runner at second two down
in the inning oh and two the count
and he started
and he got rung up by the first base
umpire stu shorewater
on the appeal he strikes out three in a
row and five in his first two big league
innings
working out of the stretch
ooh swinging a miss
crawford go after that slider for strike
three it's his second strikeout of the
afternoon not on purpose can only hope
you don't swing at it
and there's another swing and a miss and
a ball in the dirt and so duggars
strikes out
gibson adds a couple of strikeouts in
the fourth inning hard to stay back when
you got to cover 95.
got him swinging with the fastball
struck him out swinging he is piling up
the strikeout sammy long he's thinking
this is easy right now that's five in a
row
that one was a fastball and popped up by
calhoun
the save popped up carried out to medium
deep center field another one two three
inning for sammy long we go to the fifth
now the giants into the fifth inning
against kyle gibson jason bossler leads
off against him a left-handed batter
fossler drills that one to deep right
field down the line it's hooking and it
is off the foul pole
jason vossler puts the giants on the
board it's one to nothing his third big
league home run and that was a shot
great swing great drive through chadwick
trump right-handed hitter who struck out
looking his first time trump hits a high
fly ball deep left field the giants
have gone back to back
a towering home run for chadwick trump
he told you he had some power that's his
first of this year
two nothing giants
and that is strike three called so a
strikeout of wade is the second out of
the unit
3-2
is topped not in front of the plate long
will make the play to first nicely done
his early nemesis in his very young
bigly career is vanquished charlie
culvers
is an out what a four inning stretch for
sammy long he and the giants lead two
nothing
solano into the gap in right center
field garcia is going to cut it off
solano is not going to test him
and tom and solano with that leg injury
from earlier maybe still
not moving quite the way he would
swinging a miss and he strikes out
duggar
to end a scoreless sixth inning so
another
very strong outing for kyle gibson
on one pitch and this ball hit hard out
to left field that could be trouble and
the fact it gets down and bounces up
against defense
and white has another double he had one
in yesterday's game
so the rangers have their first hit of
the ball game
and it brings the potential tying run to
the plate gives up the double and now
he's coming out of the game but it is
tough to take guy out when he's got a no
hitter going he jumped in and he's doing
it well and getting fist bumps all
around what a debut that's awesome
drink it in see now he's taking it in
now he's taking that moment to look
around that's
that's when it hits you
with a good lead down at third base
and this one on the ground shortstop i
don't get a run home white scores the
throw to first in time kind of falafel
picks up an rbi it's a 2-1 ball game
ground ball in the whole shortstop and
that one
is
it's probably gonna be a base hit
crawford got to it but he couldn't get
it cleanly
one and two the count
right at the knees strike three called
inside corner
two two
and it's on the ground and pass first
base into right field base hit
the hit streak extended to eight and the
tying run on in the ninth inning for the
rangers
isaiah with ten steals he's got a little
lean going and he's taking off the
pitches strike the throw from trump
offline and that's a stolen base for
connor falefa
so the tying one is it third with one
out
brock holt moving the runner with a line
drive to center
and here comes adoles garcia
garcia reaches out lost it to shallow
right field wade coming on he can't get
to it it's down for a base hit
garcia to second and they're getting
there for the second out of the inning
but the rangers have tied it in the
ninth and again el bombay is delivered
right center field base hit
dubon had to hold up to make sure
that it wasn't caught
so he gets only the third
over the middle
one and they get the double play but the
run scores and the giants are ahead
three to two
the tying run
down that third base line and that one's
very high ball four
and now nate lowe comes to the plate
with a chance here and on the corner
and that ball in the air
center field that'll take duggar back
deep enough to get calhoun to the plate
he'll tag and score
and we are square at three again
an intentional one be up to brock holt
two strike pitch and that one's line to
center field base hit low around third
here comes the throw off line
nate low scores from second
on brock halt's base hit to center field
and the rangers solving an extra innings
win today